take a breath that was part a it's a
it's a messy looking identity but the
whole part of getting this out of our
two applications of de marvelous theorem
is because it allows us to tackle
part b so uh let's let's bring that back
into view here it is
here's part b hence oops it is i didn't
mean to rotate that
meant to make it a bit bigger and easier
to read hence solve the equation
16 5 theta equals sine 5 theta
for this particular domain okay so now
we're going back into
trigonometric equation solution land
right but how do we do this
um well you can see here that i have a
result for sine phi theta right here
from part a right
so i can substitute in instead of sine 5
theta
sine to the power of 5 theta i should
say i'm going to write in all of
this instead right so i can say from
part a
i'm going to simply substitute in
instead of writing
16 sine the power of 5 theta i'm going
to say 16 times
this because this is equivalent to
sine to the power of 5 theta so i'm
multiplying
by this and that is equal to 16
sine uh sorry i'm reading the wrong line
that's equal to sine of 5 theta so you
can see what i've done here
this is the 16 i've got from here in
fact i'll do some lines here
this is what i've got for this result
why did i choose that color that's what
i got from there the 16 goes to the 16.
you can see this sine that i have 5
theta
has become this result here which is
everything you can see there
and then if we could measure this guy
over here is the sine phi theta on both
sides and i'm solving
for naught to two pi now you might say
that looks a lot worse
this clearly looks more complicated than
this but you can see some stuff is going
to cancel isn't it for starters
those 16s are going to cancel so that
leaves me with just
this that's going to be equal to
on the right hand side sine of 5 theta
and second you can see i've got a sine 5
theta on the left
sine 5 theta on the right so those are
going to cancel so that leaves me with
just this this will equal
in fact zero i can go even further i can
subtract
five from both sides here so i'm not
subtract i can divide
both sides by five so that gives me with
sine three theta out the front
and then minus two sine theta
in the back that's all equal to 0.
now at this point here i can do one of
two things
right i can say oh well i can um sorry
let me take the back you do a lot more
than two things but there are two things
that in my mind
will be useful the first thing is you
might think okay well i can
i can add 2 sine theta both sides that
makes it look nice and neat i can say
sine 3 theta
equals 2 sine theta and this is going to
be really useful for me
later on because i have a really good
sense of what sine 3 theta and 2 sine
theta what they actually look like so
i'm going to use that as sort of an
error checking method for me later on
but for now actually keeping everything
on the left hand side and having it
equal to 0
is advantageous to me because if you
look closely here
sine 3 theta i i know what sine 3 theta
is in simpler terms that will allow me
to simplify what's going on here if you
go back to part a
you can see right here i got this result
for
sine 3 theta it's equal to 3 sine theta
minus
4 sine cubed theta so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take this
and substitute it for the sine 3 theta
that i have
on the left hand side so this
is from equation two
i can say that's minus two sine theta
and the brilliance of doing this is i
now have even though it's a bit messy
i have an equation that is entirely in
terms of sine theta so it is
very easy to deal with one type sort of
do some collecting of like terms
and also some factorization so let's
have a go
i've got these like terms that you can
see here that are sine theta and another
sine theta there
there's three take away two which is
just one last i checked
and then you've got more minus four sine
cubed theta that's all
equal to zero i can do a factorization
out of sine theta that's the common
factor
so that leaves me with sine theta out
the front 1 minus
4 sine squared theta
and that's equal to 0. so i have a
product it's equal to 0
and this will be true if either of the
factors in the product
are equal to 0 themselves so let's do
each of those separately
let's let's carry this guy over here so
if i deal with
sine theta equals 0
this is really easy in the given domain
not to 2 pi which is our standard domain
that we're quite used to dealing with
the solutions that i'm interested in for
sine theta will be
naught pi and 2 pi
and if you're wondering how i got that
so fast i have a
very basic sine theta curve in my head
and i'm looking for these
solutions here that was the whole point
of having it all equal to zero
you're just finding the x or the theta
intercepts in this case and they come
in at the start in the middle and at the
end of the standard domain so naught
pi and 2 pi then when we have a look
over at
at this part over here in order to make
1 minus 4 sine squared theta in order to
make that equal to 0
you can see i can do a bit of
simplification here i can
uh subtract 1 from both sides and also
multiply both sides by negative 1 in one
hit hopefully you're comfortable with
doing that
i'll now divide both sides by 4 which
gives me that
and a quarter is just
the square it's the square of a half
so i'm getting plus or minus a half on
the right hand side here
now that plus or minus is actually even
though it looks like it's messier it's
actually really easy because you know we
usually think of trying to work out
quadrants and that kind of thing you're
like oh sine is positive in
quadrant one and two and sine is
negative in quadrants three and four
well because i've got plus or minus here
you just get all of the quadrants so i'm
going to get a quadrant 1 2
3 and a 4 answer so therefore theta is
going to be equal to
first quadrant answer for sine theta
equals a half is just pi on 6.
your next one is going to be pi take
away that base angle so that would be 5
pi on 6. your next one will be seven pi
on six because that's pi plus your base
angle
and then lastly two pi minus your base
angle will be eleven
pi on six so um i've got
count them up uh not one not two not
three but in fact together
seven answers so i should conclude by
saying therefore
theta equals naught pi two pi
and also um i've got these guys over
here
you know to be really neat i probably
should have put them in some kind of
like ascending or descending order but
you know what
i think we've done enough work that
that's sufficient
so this thing has seven solutions that's
a bit weird but
it actually shouldn't surprise us all
that much when we go back to this idea
up here
and think about what this is going to
look like visually before we actually
graph this have a think about what these
two things are going to look like if you
think about
2 sine theta it's a regular sine curve
but it's been
its amplitude has been increased to 2
and then sine 3 theta
it's like the same sine theta function
but it's much more frequent it's triple
is frequent you're going to get three
copies of the entire period
from naught to 2 pi so because of that
frequency
and that change of amplitude let's see
if we get
what's matching here these are the seven
solutions so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to pull up desmos
over here and i've got
these two functions in mind so i'm going
to go
let's see here hopefully we can make
this nice and clear and i'm going to put
this
in terms of pi as well since i'm doing
this in radians
all right so let's have a look i want in
the first instance
sine of 3
x on the left hand side i don't want all
of it i want to restrict it
from naught to
2 pi okay there we go so you can quickly
see there
um as we were anticipating before i've
got my three copies
of uh sign x happening you've got the
the up down
and then you have it two more times as
you reach two pi so there's the first
one
and then i might make this a bit bigger
this way i think that'll do
my next one is again i want this between
norton to pi so that it graphs the
correct section
for me if i go back here i want to graph
this increased amplitude version so it's
going to be 2 sine
x instead of theta just to make it
easier for desmos to handle it so 2
sine x and then i close my brackets in
here
so this is a bit uh squishy and
difficult to read so let's just make
this a little bit bigger
all right what are we getting here well
these solutions to this equation
sine 3x equals two sine x are the points
of
intersection and what we can see really
quickly is the two sets of solutions
that i found
independently from each of the factors
um here is the first one
there's not and then pi and then two pi
which are coming up in
the you know beginning middle and end
and then i've got four more solutions
that i'm anticipating so here comes
pi on six five pi on six there's another
point intersection down there seven pi
and six and then the last one
eleven pi on six so sure enough
seven solutions a little bit strange but
it comes exactly out of the equations
and the identities
that we used